from one minute to one minute and four
seconds there's this weird moment I
cannot stop looking at there's these two
guys in the back and it looks like they
were told to be act like they're
struggling and arguing and it just looks
like the one dude is giving him the
roughest massage instructions they gave
for a background stuff this guy's not
getting stabbed
he's not getting choked it looks like he
just getting the most insane shoulder in
the same the other guys rushing to grab
the other guys but before he falls
backwards off the bench there's a
quarter of crew as then in my mind now I
look at Bevers fights going on to have a
habit of looking hella their reject
nation happy frickin Halloween - yeah
we're gonna watch the official trailer
for Netflix's The Witcher I'm wearing a
watchman shirt cuz DC Superman daredevil
Netflix and this is what I was rude
earlier
[Music]
huh
I think anyway wouldn't you do to you
the trip
Oh
judge me they say which is gonna feel
human emotion what do you believe the
bathtub
it's all the same
[Music]
dude it's so cool that that prequel
series for Game of Thrones is finally
being yep coming out this year me cate
blanchett looks badass as henry cavill
wrong joke Naomi Watts is the one who
was in that series yeah but I laughed
hey this looks awesome
this looks incredible I needs a game of
Thrones prequels I've owned though the
second season of Spartacus right now and
then of course you know what Game of
Thrones so I mean you know like slowly
getting into I'm not that familiar with
these like fantasy period shows I'm a
smart he isn't exactly fantasy but it's
kind of treated okay this reminded me
kind of a cool hybrid evolved it felt
like some aesthetic designs of obviously
reminiscent in Game of Thrones it's
going to be reminiscent of any of these
like period shows yeah watch like Rome
or tutors roofie flashing in this stuff
yeah exactly because of like the heavy
emphasis on hyper stylized action I
flashed a little bit more to Spartacus
Henry Cavill looks freaking awesome is
gerald i've never played the game you
don't have to this is based on the books
but I've said I've read borrowing I've
read all the books I read all the books
though I'm a huge huge book enthusiast
Oh totally love books best books books
well I mean it's funny though if they're
not basing it on the games at all I
watch this like compilation of cutscenes
earlier today of like all these scenes
Gerald and then watching Henry Cavill
here it seems so much like him from the
video game the delivery the body
language the voice everything about him
just reminding me so much of the
cutscenes I thought is like damn he
brought this character to life you know
I'm sure he probably mainly based about
the book well but it's kind of ironic
that to watch the game footage in like
writing me a lot of the game actually oh
yeah well I mean they they easily come
out of each other they're easily very
related to each other I just know that
from what they've said that the main
bulk of the adaptation will come from
the books but they say they're gonna
homage little Easter eggs to the game
they're open to that stuff I mean there
is a bathtub with Henry Cavill in it and
there's a very prominent bathtub meme
from these games so like I don't know if
that's the exact reference there but um
you know I think you're confused I
believe it's from BBS when Clark Kent
gets into the bathtub with Amy
that's right so that's what they're all
sexiest scenes make sure you get your
facts right hi Joe for you sounds stupid
on the internet that's I'm always stupid
on the internet but that's they said I
don't know what if this is a chicken or
egg situation but they said Henry Cavill
is a big fan of the series and has read
all the books and played all the games
and stuff so like if that's true that's
pretty neat but he gets to step in and
fill the shoes because he does actually
feel not just like oh this guy's hot
right now I actually does feel like
pretty good casting from the look of
this yeah I do think that it's
interesting I mean that Game of Thrones
prequel series fell through and then I
see a trailer like this this kind of
reminds me of if Game of Thrones did not
work so hard to crush its fantasy
elements where are you getting that idea
yeah I don't know man wouldn't be the
way the showrunners have recently
started airing out all their dirty
laundry how much they didn't want to do
all that fantasy stuff and they weren't
really sure how to run a show like this
yeah yeah I have a lot of football
player cousins and they wanna they
wanted to watch Game of Thrones
oh of course I've been riding that
fantasy craps oh yeah yeah no no they
got an air into politics and my tennis
friends are gonna be watching this show
tennis players I've ever I've seen one
swords are a lot like tennis racks you
know rackets we made a word totally yes
an interesting marketing choice with how
they're doing this shredder because I
remember that when the other one came
out it's like it was a heavy emphasis on
like you know tone introduction scope
and whatnot of course it's much more
elaborated upon those things and they
kind of kept Henry Cavill a mystery and
he wasn't as prominently featured but
this is really goes out of its way to go
know this is his show he's the star of
this series you know he's the main
character and he's gonna be the
protagonist that were primarily
following you know his courage to see
some of that little glimpse for some
reason the one thing about my mind is
like nudity oh yeah
there's from what I understand out
plenty you right to go around and dab
suppress really I mean let's slow it
down here is it not it's it's out of
focus out it's it's pretty you can tell
I mean if you're there's gotta be some
kids out there on the internet pausing
and zooming in
forms silhouettes this does not look
like a TV show could easily be it looks
like HBO it looks like Netflix has
really stepped up their game with with
this because this looks like a
full-blown awesome cinema and the other
thing too is I think it's good that they
chose to do a show with something like
this because I feel like most of the
fanbase currently and our generation is
from the video games yeah and not so
much with the books but either way if
you're adapting book or game it's best
to make that a TV show oh yeah
it's cool that they're not skimping out
on the fantasy elements because usually
with movies that have this level of
fantasy and fuse and it's war epic stale
medieval vibes they'll still work to
make it pg-13 and not R and this feels
like it's gonna be a pretty hard R which
is necessary for the full impact of the
series it's weird I feel like ours are
risky in the movies but mature audience
ratings are not as risky on TV cuz I
don't know for some reason I feel like
just pulp thrives on television and the
main thing from this trailer that I like
I love the look of the scope it
definitely looks like netflix has money
I mean for as much trouble as everybody
keeps talking about there they seem to
be at least right now throwing down and
my main thing is just like I want to see
what they can show runners keep talking
about how at the core of all this it's
about these like two or three characters
who are this misshapen little family
who's gonna be the core spirit of the
show that's something that I have no
indication for as of either of these
trailers I imagine it's a hard to put a
true personal like the personal
protagonist element cuz they made a big
deal about it's gonna be Geralt in these
couple other people who don't belong
together and sort of don't get along but
clearly have this linked to each other
enough and that's gonna be an important
you know emotional arc of the show all
right guys we decided for The Witcher
did you prefer this trailer over the
last what do you do for Halloween today
nothing it's a Thursday they should just
move Halloween's at the on Fridays
Halloween should be like Easter whereas
just
always on a yawn a weekend day or
something yeah or like Thanksgiving how
it's always on the last Thursday you
know just like save the last day of
October November after October 30th and
then drop the 31st back in when there's
a good day for Halloween is a Thursday
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
I got you guys soon